we got back there
oh your son and your daughter and how
old are these two
22 24. okay and so and who who brought
who you bring them or they I'm your fan
that he did he wow okay
the youngest paid that's very nice you
brought your mom how'd your [__]
sister sneak in on that
what's that
you're his favorite you're his only
sibling so
oh you're not you're not how old the
other siblings
that's right I forgot what state I was
in
I forgot I forgot yeah that's right
yeah your your family could have filled
up this [__] section I got it
mom just had another one look at that
that was [__]
that's how good that joke was it got her
pregnant
[Applause]
who are you who are you here with
your mom okay how old are you man
nope
I don't give a [__] enough to guess uh
you want to tell me how old you are
almost 30. okay and so who brought who
she suggested you come so otherwise so
you're still living at the house and she
was like I'm going out do you want a car
did you hear him behind you no no
mom tell him no no
okay cool man what's your name man
Jayden good to meet you interesting grab
bag I'm not gonna lie to you yeah
yeah
we got the [__] Viagra 8 back there
that's nice
we got Jaden who definitely doesn't live
at home
[Laughter]
so in back who who's who's in back who's
back there
like you know what I love the way you're
saying it like you're on Family Feud I
really love the way you're
he's got that kind of pitch I got my
brother here I got my wife here got my
sister here my best friend's here
[Applause]
survey says that's the number one answer
I like that [__]
yeah yeah who you got
your son who where is he how old are you
dude
45. all right so yeah yeah
[Music]
you hear how he said it he's like I
don't know why not okay
yeah so you're you're basically and and
who brought who you're her caretaker you
brought yeah I ever you brought her yeah
I uh
somebody heard that joke I mumbled under
my breath okay I appreciate it